president Emma Simon and echoes
relationship with Robert Mugabe was not
always easy but on Friday he praised the
man he replaced as a principal comrade
who'd made huge sacrifices for his
country the remains of our dear departed
icon we pray that the good Lord grant
him Messi's putting his dear soul to
eternal rest
we as bobbins the days of mourning for
our leader until his barracks Mugabe
died in Singapore where he had been
receiving treatment for several years he
was 95 years old Mugabe leaves a
complicated legacy to some he was a hero
and African legend that his education
policy is the reason why Zimbabwe has
one of the highest literacy rates in
Africa
greatly and he knew that to make a great
country a great education and he made it
possible for all the kids of Zimbabwe to
get their free and fair choice of
learning but others point to a history
of disputed elections and trans
corruption allegations of human rights
abuses and political and economic
turmoil destroyed our man and tillich
was nothing that men was a really really
bad man he did nothing for our nation in
fact what it did is it planned as I seem
to disaster everything opposition
leaders say some of Mugabe's black
empowerment policies such as land reform
and indigenous Asian [ __ ] the economy
and government services the fact that he
has had to pass on in foreign land is
something that points to their problems
that we have in our country we can't
have our leaders in Africa being treated
in foreign lands we must be able to fix
our politics fix our governance
institutions fix our governance systems
so that we have big ideas not just big
men big institutions not just because in
our personality Mugabe remains a
polarizing figure but government
officials say who be treated with
respect and dignity
gieux to Zimbabwe founding father Robert
Mugabe will be given a state funeral his
body will lie in state for
three days then he will be buried at the
national hero cemetery in the capital
where many people who fought to end
white minority rule are buried Carew
Mutasa al-jazeera Hourani